bienvenue à tous vous regardez parlement
hebdo 45 minutes d'actualité politique
et parlementaire avec aude moracchini
bonjourbonjour michael et bonjour à tous
a passé en revue toute l'actualité cette
semaine la grande conférence sociale un
test majeur pour la méthode hollande
en lançant cette concertation avec tous
les parlementaires sociaux le président
ambitionne de créer un nouveau pacte
social à la française pas de grande
annonce à l'issue de ces débats d'une
feuille de route et un agenda des
réformes pour cinq ans et le premier
chaque social d'envergure pour le
gouvernement psa peugeot citroën annonce
la suppression de 8000 emplois l'état
qui refuse la restructuration voulue par
psa françois hollande fait part de sa
vive préoccupation quel avenir pour le
site mais aussi pour l'ensemble de la
ville d'aulnay sous bois et le
département
c'est ce que nous verrons avec notamment
le maire de la ville
enfin débat accéléré pour loi urgente le
texte sur le harcèlement sexuel a été
votée au sénat
deux mois après l'annulation par le
conseil constitutionnel
les associations manifester devant le
sénat pour elle la loi reste confuse et
avec nous pour commenter cette actualité
gérard larcher bonjour merci d'être avec
nous sur ce plateau
ancien président du sénat bien sûr tout
le monde le sait vous êtes redevenu
peut-on dire simple sénateur depuis
jeudi dernier
voilà dans un sénat passé à gauche
avaient également été ministre délégué à
l'emploi et au travail sous les
gouvernements raffarin et villepin
envers sont deux thèmes qui ont dominé
l'actualité de la semaine nous y
reviendront peut-être première question
qui vous concerne ça fait quoi de
redevenir simple sénateur généralement
sa demande il ya certain temps
d'autre part je vis moi dans une
tradition personnel ou un jour on peut
être évêque le land ma vie caire donc ça
ne me pose aucune difficulté
je suis représentant mon département les
yvelines je travaille à la commission
des affaires étrangères et de la défense
en y appliquant d'ailleurs je pense
c'est largement et en même temps je suis
naturellement les questions sociales les
questions de compétitivité les questions
hospitalière avec une très très grande
attention et bien entendu je suis un
politique qui agit et qui sait voilà ya
une chose que peut-être content c'est un
petit peu moins c'est que vous êtes
aussi administrateur du château de
chambord notamment d'été chasse du
château de chambord les chasses zealand
l'établissement public va alors voir
préciser un petit peu les choses mais
notamment c'est un chasseur également à
temps les chambord ça n'est pas que la
chasse je rappelle que la loi 2005 a
fixé pour chambord c'est d'abord un lieu
extraordinaire de patrimoine avec plus
de 800 milles visiteurs qui découvrent
le château c'est un lieu de culture en
ce moment il ya merveilleux festival à
chambord jusqu'à la fin du mois à
festival à ses divers notamment avec une
dominante musicale
il ya des expositions
la deuxième dimension de chambord c'est
naturellement son insertion très
particulière dans un univers forestier
le plus grand cloud en europe avec une
fonction de réserve nationale réserve
nationale de chasse avec vocation
notamment travaux scientifiques
il faut rester là il ya une petite
arrière pensée c'est un endroit où on
invite beaucoup c'est surtout un endroit
les jeunes éducateurs attendent et
naturellement il faut réguler
naturellement il appartient au domaine
national de chambord de procéder à cette
révélation là bas eh bien nous sommes en
train de déterminer
actuellement il ya les parlementaires il
ya des acteurs de la vie économique et
il ya aussi ceux qui font la trame de la
chasse dans notre pays notamment les
administrateurs et présidents de
fédérations que vous l'avez rap et vous
êtes aussi politique
la présidence en 2014 retour à la
présidence du sénat ça peut vous
intéresser
2014 c'est d'abord
la re conquête territoriale pour la
nouvelle opposition la re conquête
territoriale c'est à dire de retrouver
l'assise dans les communes de france que
nous avons progressivement perdu en une
dizaine d'années comme ça mais ça finit
aussi peut être
c'est là la musique en fait c'est la
logique si le territoire nous fait à
nouveau largement confiance et bien le
choix des délégués sénatoriaux pourrait
amener à un rééquilibrage politique
pour représenter qui présentait aussi
après c'est une décision que prendront
les sénateurs le moment bien ça leur
appartient
en tous les cas je participerai la re
conquête territoriale de toutes mes
forces
alors nous allons commenter ensemble
l'actualité de la semaine j'ai relâché
on commence le lundi avec la formule du
jour le compromis positif
françois hollande a inaugurée en ce
lundi la grande conférence sociale
réunissant ministres patronat et
syndicats de salariés il a insisté sur
ce fameux ce fameux mot de compromis
positif en quelque sorte un dialogue qui
mènera des mesures concrètes
en attendant avenue d'iéna à paris on
discute
jean métier daoulas le dialogue social
version françois hollande c'est avant
tout la recherche du compromis pour le
nouveau président c'est une petite
révolution culturelle qui attend le pays
la démarche que je vous propose est
nouvelle à bien des égards la france par
ses traditions par son histoire par son
organisation par son mouvement social
n'a pas développé ce qu'on appelle une
culture de la négociation sur la forme
après cinq ans d'une présidence sarkozy
marqué par sa méfiance vis-à-vis des
partenaires sociaux la méthode hollande
séduit aussi bien les syndicats que le
patronat le président de la république
nous a
propose d'inscrire y compris dans la
constitution la place du dialogue social
c'est à dire la place de la négociation
c'est une demande de la cgt depuis des
dizaines d'années c'est pas une lune de
miel cécile fou c'est plutôt je trouve
là la conscience partagée de la gravité
de la situation
sur le fond françois hollande a défini
les trois grands défis de la france
le redressement des comptes publics la
détérioration de la compétitivité et le
chômage
pour y arriver les partenaires sociaux
ont débattu tout l'après midi autour de
cette table ronde
chacune animé par un ministre de quoi
définir une feuille de route pour les
prochains mois mais l'absence de mesures
concrètes risque déjà de laisser le
patronat et les syndicats sur leur faim
il ne faut pas que sous couvert de
négociations avec le patronat
on tergiverse sur des sujets d'urgence
en fin de journée le bilan est plutôt
positif
mais force ouvrière n'a pas apprécié la
table ronde sur le redressement
productif passé l'essentiel du temps sur
un sujet jusqu'à maintenant tous les cas
sur un sujet qui est la stratégie
industrielle à parler de coût du travail
et de structure des prélèvements
obligatoires
je vois vraiment pas l'intérêt on en
train de perdre son temps selon adam
cette conférence comme quoi avant de
trouver un compromis sur des solutions
les partenaires sociaux devront déjà se
mettre d'accord sur les thèmes des
discussions et à l'issue des deux
journées de la conférence le premier
ministre a annoncé un calendrier de
négociations notamment pour la réforme
du smic l'encadrement des licenciements
économiques ou encore les modalités du
contrat de génération
gérard larcher votre regard d'ancien
mise de travail sur ce retour en force
de la concertation et ce retour en force
j'allais dire c'est logique en début
d'une législature et en début d'un
mandat présidentiel
en fait tout ça s'appuie sur une loi que
je connais bien qu'est la loi de janvier
2007 que j'avais soutenu est présenté à
la demande de jacques chirac et
dominique de villepin mais qui était la
motivation mon entrée au gouvernement en
en effet je pense qu'il faut donner à la
négociation sociale toute sa part à la
condition bien sûr que cette négociation
sociale se fasse entre partenaires
représentatifs
voilà pourquoi il faut lier cette
négociation
social la mise en place de la
représentativité qu'elles soient des
salariés auxquels soit les représentants
des entreprises
c'est donc un outil très utile qui donne
à la démocratie sociale sa dimension
tout en préservant la primauté de la
démocratie politique et c'est vrai qu'on
a beaucoup entendu ce maître mot de
concertation mais n'y avait pas eu
beaucoup d'annoncés en tout cas pas
beaucoup de concret alors beaucoup de
concertation fed annonce concrète et
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous ce que
je pense surtout c'est un con que ces
syndicats
au fond derrière j'allais dire ce qui
n'est pas un alibi et sans doute une
volonté de concertation au fond est ce
qu'on s'est attaqué à la question de
l'emploi
et ça c'est le sujet numéro un de
préoccupation au sujet de la
compétitivité
ça c'est le vrai sujet tout à fait
essentiel et puis derrière cela au fond
on voit arriver la cg qui remplace la
tva antidélocalisation d'aller dire tout
ça pour ça méfions nous de ne pas lâcher
si ces décès la tva sociale de la gauche
c'est ça vous voulez bien en tous les
cas la tva anti délocalisation avait un
avantage c'est que le taxer les produits
d'importation et un moment on se pose la
question de déséquilibre de concurrence
entre des pays à bas coûts et ceux qui
ont un modèle social différent
j'allais dire abandonnez l'outil cg vous
le savez je m'étais exprimé au moment du
notamment du débat sur la dépendance je
crois qu'on a un certain nombre d'outils
parmi lesquels la tva parmi lesquels la
cg parmi lesquels crds une cg
différencier d'ailleurs sur le
patrimoine ou le capital et bien d'un
seul coup on a l'impression qu'il
faudrait défaire ce qu'ont fait les
prêts 10 heures pour faire différent
est ce qu'il ne serait pas temps de nous
posions la question dans la diversité de
notions sensibilité de plutôt qu'aux
construire que d'abord détruire pour
reconstruire chez j'allais dire sur ce
point une approche de latitude que je
vois aujourd'hui la nouvelle majorité
j'allais dire l'anti-sarko nice n'a pas
de sens aujourd'hui il est toujours là
en tous les cas je le vois parce qu'un
certain nombre de décisions utiles quand
j'entends sur le logement par exemple
le logement le record de construction de
logements sociaux en france depuis 30
ans c'est sous nicolas en 2010 s'élargir
rapidement
nicolas sarkozy sur la fin de son
quinquennat s'en était pris vraiment
directement aux syndicats aux corps
intermédiaires mais surtout aux
syndicats en laissant 30 c'était un
frein finalement aux réformes
nécessaires vous partagez cette table
ronde à l'époque en disant que moi je
pense que les corps intermédiaires sont
indispensables simplement je sais je
suis de ceux qui est plaider pour la
réforme de l'europe représentativité
charlie ferroviaire maintenant à votre
parti l'ump et à la lutte qui s'annonce
pour la présidence françois fillon seul
candidat officiel pour l'instant au tam
un tour de france des fédérations ump
jusqu'au congrès du mois de novembre
pour sa première sortie il s'est rendu
dans le loiret face aux militants
l'occasion pour l'ancien premier
ministre de rappeler ses ambitions pour
l'écouter
j'ai été pendant cinq ans premier
ministre et chef de la majorité
mon rôle c'était de prendre des
décisions en liaison avec la majorité
aujourd'hui mon rôle c'est d'aller
écouter les militants pour construire
avec eux un projet d'alternance
gérard larcher où vous avez fait votre
choix votre choix c'est la personne
combien d'écouté françois fillon
pourquoi parce que c'est l'antithèse de
jean françois copé
non pas du tout mon choix c'est d'abord
l'union pour un mouvement populaire qui
est mon mouvement politique la
imaginerait dans lequel j'ai pu
m'exprimer avec beaucoup de liberté y
compris quand j'ai eu des désaccords sur
des questions comme la laïcité tout le
monde le sait le bouclier fiscal voire
des interrogations sur la réforme
territoriale au cours du quinquennat qui
vient de s'achever mais j'assume la
totalité de j'allais dire de ce qui a
été fait au cours de ce quinquennat
françois fillon parce qu'il me semble
être celui qui peut rassembler dans
notre diversité
celui qui porta certain nombre de
valeurs qui nous ont amenés à construire
l'ump en 2002 de liberté de
responsabilité de solidarité et je dois
dire que il m'apparaît être celui que
les françaises et les français peuvent
écouter car naturellement ces tâches
watts d'adhérents et de militants il ne
peut pas être déconner
tu es du sentiment des français en même
temps je les dis je le redis jean
françois copé timbaut secrétaire général
et ce qui compte pour moi ça me semble
naturel qu'un grand mouvement politique
après notamment un double échec
électoral se pose des questions
satire anges et surtout et un débat ce
n'est pas un combat c'est un débat puis
un choix c'est finalement le
fonctionnement démocratique d'un grand
mouvement politique
tout ça est sain et naturel à vous
l'avez dit ce sont vos valeurs qu'un
débat actuellement à l'ump un débat très
fort sur les valeurs de l'ump
est-ce que c'était pour le moment ce
débat ou pas je crois que c'est une
erreur
non je pense pas que ce soit une erreur
moi personnellement je n'ai pas doute de
doutes sur les valeurs parcours
visiblement certains noms
oui mais moi je n'en ai pas sur les
valeurs qui nous ont amenés à nous
retrouver ensemble en 2002 c'est plutôt
la traduction du projet que nous pouvons
proposer le moment venu en alternance
aux français comment on répond par
exemple au défi j'allais dire de l'échec
de nous devons tous assumer du système
éducatif parce que je regardais quand
j'ai fait mon rapport sur la formation
professionnelle en avril cent vingt
mille jeunes sortaient du système
scolaire
alors sans qualification et sans
formation aujourd'hui sont 140 milles
entre temps on a terminé la réforme haby
on à massifier le lycée entre temps on a
embauché des dizaines de milliers
d'enseignés en plus et il faut se poser
la question je prends cet exemple là
parce qu'il faut d'abord que sont l'ump
quand même attendez un parti politique
ça porte un projet et sur apporte des
idées mais les sages ils ont changé d'un
des bars autres personnes aussi c'est
naturel pas contre personnes entre
sensibilité nous voyons bien que par
exemple la place des centristes qui est
un élément pour le gaulliste social qui
est très très important pour moi
à l'intérieur de l'ump mérite une
attention particulière
j'ai vu que les les centristes qui
n'étaient pas dans l'ump d'ailleurs
considéré en réponse aux fléaux et est
en capacité de rassembler co2
deux candidats seulement vous pensez
juste un match fillon copé il faudra
pour cela peut y avoir beaucoup d'amis
là il ya de vrais légitimité à
l'intérieur j'ai vu bertrand réfléchi
être candidat n'a juppé pour être
candidat d'autres pourraient l'être mais
je veux dire c'est sain et naturel qu'un
grand mouvement politique
voilà pourquoi j'ai trouvé ça et naturel
souvenez vous en 2008 quand nous avons
eu un choix à l'intérieur d'un groupe
qu'on savoir qui serait candidat
la démocratie à l'intérieur d'un
mouvement politique ou d'un groupe
politique
c'est naturel allez on va passer au
mardi mais qui est donc responsable de
l'endettement de la france en ce mardi
donc les députés se penchent sur les
comptes de la nation ceux de 2013 avec
le débat d'orientation budgétaire qui
fixe le premier cadre du prochain projet
de loi de finances et puis il y a eu un
retour sur les comptes de 2011 ça
s'appelle le règlement des comptes et
évidemment cela a tourné au règlement de
comptes sur cette fameuse question
d'héritage fiscale petit échange à trois
et cinq dernières années
structurellement et indépendamment de la
crise notre pays à continuer à
s'endetter à dépenser plus qu'ils ne
percevaient bref à mener une politique
de finances publiques que jacques de
molay brûlé pour cela condamné et que le
roi de france y avait brûlé jacques de
molay avait précisément menée à l'époque
mes chers collègues
la conclusion est je le crains sans
appel pour ceux qui ont eu à présider
aux destinées du pays ces cinq dernières
années ils ont laissé le pays sans d'été
dans la dette et c'est désormais à une
nouvelle majorité un nouveau
gouvernement à l'en sortir
je n'ai pas le temps de vous parler ni
de jacques de molay ni dans guérande
mari guy je ne voudrais vous parler que
d'une seule chose c'est de la
remarquable gestion du gouvernement
fillon pendant toute l'année
milo en soixante ans d'histoire
budgétaire il n'était jamais arrivé dans
notre pays que les dépenses de l'état
diminue d'un exercice par rapport au
précédent
monsieur carrese qui s'est exprimé
pendant tout son propos uniquement à
l'opposition n'est pas ici président de
l'ump seul mais de la commission des
finances tout entière la fonction de
monsieur perez était imminente mais il
ya plus important encore c'est d'être à
la hauteur de cette mission
force est de constater aujourd'hui que
monsieur car elle n'a pas été à la
hauteur de la fonction qu'il a un
président de la commission des finances
qui fait partie de l'opposition tout de
suite ça met de l'ambiance
finalement vous avez adopté aussi la
même règle au sénat le sénat a adopté la
même règle ce n'était pas moi puisque
j'étais président j'étais attentif très
attentifs et l'opposition mais il faut
que ce ne l'ont pas suivant ce système
serait simplement dire je vois cet
échange au delà de ce qu'elle peut avoir
théâtral et j'allais dire depuis 30 ans
sous tous les gouvernements
notre pays a vécu un peu drogués à la
dépense publique et c'est vraiment en
2011 que nous avons commencé à diminuer
réellement les dépenses de l'état et
j'allais le dire et je les assume et son
la campagne sénatoriale les dépenses la
nécessaire décélération des dépenses des
collectivités territoriales se dévouent
des cris d'orfraie que nous entendions
chez les socialistes comme le premier
ministre ou moi même nous évoquions ce
sujet aujourd'hui nous sommes face à une
réalité il est faux de dire que la crise
n'a eu aucune incidence n'est pas vrai
le plan de relance a été nécessaire pour
éviter l'envolée du chômage pour
soutenir l'activité
aujourd'hui la première des priorités
c'est de diminuer un certain nombre de
dépenses publiques de privilégier les
dépenses susceptibles d'améliorer notre
compétitivité parce que la seule vérité
si nous voulons préserver un modèle
social c'est créer des richesses alors
je ne sais pas créer de richesse si je
ne crée pas d'emplois et là mon
expérience de ministre du travail
elle m'a démontré que c'est la seule
manière de créer
emploi nous avons fait baisser le
chômage entre 2005 et 2008
parce que nous avons une croissance au
dessus de nous qu'on revient peut-être
la grande conférence sociale quand il
n'y a pas eu d'annoncé forcément sur la
compétitivité et qu'on le medef dit
qu'il n'ya on ne travaille sur la
compétitivité n'est pas fait nous dit
qu'ils n' erreurs des gouvernements
actuels jean-marc il faut que le
gouvernement actuel face de la
compétitivité
sa priorité la compétitivité c'est bien
sûr le coût du travail et on le voit
dans le secteur automobile
c'est l'investissement dans la recherche
développement c'est la priorité donnée à
la formation professionnelle initiale
comme sela au jour suite
attendez on va voir dans lesquelles est
annoncée je n'insiste quoi qu'on traite
à 60 ans +0 1 charges salariales
diminution j'allais dire du soutien aux
heures supplémentaires
voilà deux exemples que je vous donne
qui concrètement à l'ordinateur
d'irrigation des entreprises la charge
des entreprises et donc la priorité
c'est la compétitivité
moi je vais observer beaucoup
d'attention les travaux louis gallois
est un homme de qualité sur cette
question de la compétitivité
je me souviens de ce qu'il disait sur la
compétitivité de eads et d'airbus à un
moment où la parité euro/dollar était
extrêmement défaveur de la compétitivité
de l'aéronautique européenne retourne au
sénat le dernier texte adopté sous le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy est le
premier à être abrogée par la gauche
permettre l'agrandissement des maisons
avec le minimum de contraintes sénat a
mis fin à la majoration de ce que l'on
appelle le droit à construire la
ministre du logement s'explique dans
l'hémicycle on va écouter tout de suite
cécile duflot la loi du 20 mars 2012
et vous l'avez tous dit avant moi et est
le fruit d'une initiative très largement
improvisé qui n'a donné lieu qu'à un
simulacre de concertation avec les
acteurs du logement faire croire que la
loi de majoration des droits à
construire allait permettre la relance
de l'offre de logements en facilitant
l'agrandissement des logements existants
ou la production de logements nouveaux
et est un leurre on a pu s'en rendre
compte
gérard larcher on va parler du fond dans
une seconde mais j'ai une petite
question
abrogation des lois ce qu'on appelle
vulgairement le d
tricotage des lois sarkozy ça commence
ici au sénat avec cette loi on savait
qu'on dansait dès le mois d'octobre
souvenez vous il ya eu des votes de
dizaines de milliards mais la mi-temps
on en avait eu un avant goût
moi je crois que c'est pas une bonne
manière je vous le disais il ya un
instant
pourquoi ne pas avoir pris le temps je
rappelle que cette formule de croissance
de 30 % duco ce n'était pas obligatoire
à certain nombre de communes dont la
mienne rambouillet qui avait privilégié
le logement social
pas loin de 30 % de logements sociaux
dans ma commune qui avaient privilégié
notamment les formes alternatives
d'énergie et qui avait donné du corps
supplémentaires
nous apprécions à 2 à ne pas appliquer
parce que la loi le prévoyait et que
d'ailleurs mais c'est là avait été
attentifs et à ce que ça ne soit pas
obligatoire
est-ce qu'on peut pas se donner un petit
peu de temps parce qu'au fond le vrai
sujet c'est construire des logements est
d'abord construire des logements sociaux
or c'est en 2010 qu'on a construit le
plus de logements dont 130 mille
logements sociaux à comparer aux 40
mille logements de l'année 2000 ce
monsieur j'ose pas la priorité c'est
cela libérer les terrains notamment de
l'état pour construire des logements qui
suis extrêmement favorable d'autant que
le précédent gouvernement l'avait déjà
fait mais permettant la construction de
55 mille logements seraient d'accord
pour dire qu'il avait une sorte de chape
de plomb pour les mères avec cette loi
de 30% supplémentaires par une chape de
plomb les mères avaient la possibilité
sans sortir puisque le maire de
rambouillet avait engagé la procédure
pour ne pas l'appliquer
donc ça s'appelle pas une chape de plomb
ça s'appelle une chape où il ya des
lucarnes dont on peut sortir
elle va passer mercredi avec l'arrivée
au sénat de la loi sur le harcèlement
sexuel
après le flou reprocher la précédente
loi sur le harcèlement sexuel est
invalidée par le conseil constitutionnel
eh bien c'est la complexité du nouveau
texte qui est critiqué le gouvernement a
voulu aller vite trop vite peut-être en
tout cas les sénateurs ont retravaillé
le texte les sanctions sont aggravées
mais la définition du délit reste
complexe toutes les explications avec
thomas raguet il y a deux mois ils
disparaissaient du code pénal il y fait
aujourd'hui son retour le harcèlement
sexuel sera désormais ainsi définit le
harcèlement sexuel et le fait d'imposer
à une personne de façon répétée des
propos ou agissements à connotation
sexuelle
la réitération madame la sénatrice c'est
le propre même du harcèlement certains
sénateurs à l'image d'associations de
défense de victimes auraient préféré une
définition simple ne faisant pas
référence au caractère répétitif des
avances
ils regrettent par ailleurs que l'on
puisse désormais assimilé à du
harcèlement sexuel des comportements
unique qui relèverait davantage
d'agressions sexuelles sur ce point la
garde des sceaux s'est voulu rassurant
il ne s'agit pas d'utiliser cet acte
unique pour des qualifiés par exemple
des infractions plus graves tels que
l'agression sexuelle ou le viol qui
n'est pas seulement des patients qui est
un crime
au final la majorité se dit satisfaite
par ce nouveau texte
je crois qu'on la meilleure parce qu'on
couvre beaucoup plus de cas qu
auparavant
et puis je crois qu'on améliore à cause
d'un amendement qui est adoptée hier et
qui est passée un peu inaperçue c'est et
non sur la vulnérabilité économique et
social
quand vous êtes dans la situation de
détresse économique c'est là où vous
êtes potentiellement plus la victime
donc je crois qu'on a fait un beau
travail en ajoutant ce ce point dans le
texte une nouvelle définition du
harcèlement sexuel qui sur le fond fait
consensus à gauche comme à droite
nous sommes d'accord avec l'
architecture du projet de loi est et ce
qui a été retenu par d'ailleurs
essentiellement par le groupe de travail
et par la commission des lois à
l'assemblée nationale devrait pour sa
part voté conforme d'ici la fin juillet
gérard larcher pourquoi est ce que c'est
si difficile de s'entendre sur la
définition de harcèlement sexuel on l'a
encore vu là dans le sujet la loi reste
quand même un petit peu flou non d'abord
il faut noter que nous avons été
unanimes pour voter
ce texte sur en même temps chantal
jouanno me ghedini ont posé un certain
nombre d'interrogations avec la
préoccupation de protéger du harcèlement
san actes répétitifs ou non et jean
jacques hyest a dit à nouveau
l'importance d'être clair et précis dans
les arguments jury n'est peut-être là je
comprend l'urgence
je comprend l'urgence et sans doute je
leur ai partagé mais on ne sait pas
suffisamment inspiré de cette
proposition de dois me semble-t-il qu'il
s'énerve et et notamment du sénat on
légifère souvent bien vite trop vite
trop vite parfois et ceux qui nous qu'on
peut nous conduire par des questions
prioritaires de constitutionnalité
demain car je n'imagine pas que ce texte
soit déférée sauf initiative du
président du sénat ou du président de
l'assemblée nationale puisque qu'ils
pourraient demander conseil
constitutionnel son avis pour en quelque
sorte conforter le texte
eh bien nous courons un risque mais
d'accord vous êtes d'accord pour dire
qu'on est allé encore une fois un petit
peu trop vite pour les cons vérité mais
jean jacques hyest est championne joie
nous l'avait dit dès le départ sur tours
ne s'est pas suffisamment
inspiré des travaux parlementaires
toujours la tentation d'exécutif quel
qu'il soit quelle que soit sa couleur à
l'est j'arrive avec mon taxi est ce qui
ne vous convient pas exactement ce que
je ne suis pas spécialiste comme jean
jacques hyest de ses dimensions
jean jacques et ça a été notre président
de la commission des lois mais je crois
que des notions de précisions j'allais
dire pour tout simplement protéger ceux
qui peuvent être victimes du harcèlement
de la qualification toujours temps
toujours autour du même problème sur ce
qu'est la question allez on repasse par
l'assemblée dans l'une des salles du
palais bourbon se joue en ce mercredi un
petit événement politique la création
d'un nouveau parti un parti centriste
née d'une dissidence du nouveau centre
et c'est jean christophe lagarde qui va
être le président de cette force
européenne démocrate
il lui restera à trouver sa place car
dans la galaxie centriste il ya déjà six
partis existants germain andrieu
c'est une planète de plus dans la
galaxie centriste la fed
la force européenne démocrate de jean
christophe lagarde
l'objectif de l'ex numéro deux du
nouveau centre
simplifier la situation c'est pour
rendre lisible aux yeux de l'opinion
publique la possibilité de faire une
confédération comme l'était l'udf
c'était très visible pour l'opinion
publique et c'est la séparation la vie
en petite chapelle qui ne permet pas
cette lisibilité c'est justement ce que
nous voulons bousculer bousculer les
chapelles pour créer une cathédrale
c'est notre objectif
en attendant la cathédrale ce nouveau
parti est le septième du centre droit si
l'on prend en compte l'ambigu modem de
françois bayrou
le nouveau centre de hervé morin la
convention démocrate de hervé de
charette l'alliance centriste de jean
arthuis
la gauche moderne de jean marie bockel
sans oublier bien sûr le parti radical
valoisien de jean-louis borloo
mais entre une confédération ou un
nouveau grand parti à l'image de l'udf
rien n'est encore tranché je crois que
le modèle qui peut réussir c'est la
construction d'un nouveau parti
politique au centre droit de la vie
politique d'un parti large qui
rassemblerait tout le monde et pas une
juxtaposition de chapelles donc il ya un
débat à avoir entre nous j'ai dit qu'il
fallait c'est les ego de côté
quand on regarde une fois de plus
difficultés de la france avec ou
politiques ambitieuses et courageuses
qu'il faut réveiller les plans sociaux
qui arrive ce problème de compétitivité
nos bricolage et nos petites chapelles
nos problèmes que l'on peut rencontrer
au sein des centristes n'intéresse pas
les français ce qu'ils veulent c'est des
hommes et des femmes capables de prendre
des responsabilités et de montrer un
chemin et pour montrer le chemin du
centre
un seul leader naturel est attendue jean
louis borloo le président du parti
radical pourrait prendre la tête d'un
grand rassemblement au plus tôt pour la
rentrée mais pour le moment aucun
calendrier officiel n'a été fixée alors
lâchez vous faites partie de cette droit
social qui se rapproche du centre
voilà un député philippe vigier qui
parle de bricolage vous voyez comment
vous là la création de ce septième parti
centriste alors comme gaulliste social
qui est mon positionnement politique et
et j'allais dire les racines de mon
engagement je veux dire que le centre
est une réalité de la vie politique
française
bien sûr c'est une réalité nous le
voyons dans l'expression y compris
parfois un peu perdus d'un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens au moment des
élections
j'ai vu l'apport par exemple centristes
y compris dans l'élection dans ma
circonscription c'est une des rares qui
a été reprise à la gauche et aux
écologistes celle de rambouillet où
finalement 2e tour jean frédéric poisson
rassemble largement y compris les voix
qui s'étaient exprimés existe dans ce
pays il existe à l'intérieur de l'ump
aussi et je pense qu'il appartient à nos
amis centristes de s'organiser de se
fédérer tout le monde sait l'amitié que
j'ai eu jean louis borloo tout bon c'est
aussi l'amitié avec jean arthuis et
françois zocchetto ici je crois qu'il
peut se construire à côté d'une ump
largement rassembleuse un centre et
ensemble de prêts par an l'alternance
politique visiblement n'en prend pas
vraiment le chemin et ce sans sommeil
avait plutôt indépendant biologie ce que
que je suis c'est qu'avant tout synthèse
il ya toujours un mouvement vibrionnait
qui permet ensuite la construction
je crois que c'est l'intérêt de
l'opposition est ce que le centre puisse
s'organiser
je dédie invoquons feria il ya peu de
temps je considère et je souhaite aussi
que le centre soit présent à l'intérieur
de m
gérard larcher quand même
une question n'allez pas voir ou côté
taquin là dessus mais entre
jean-françois copé et françois fillon
lequel des deux plus à même de parler
aux centristes
je pense que c'est françois fillon là
aussi c'est mon sentiment et ça n'est
nullement je vais dire une mise en doute
de qualité jean françois copé mais parce
que je pense que il sait capacité à
rassembler elle existe chez françois
fillon en tous les cas moi je
participerai aux débats à l'intérieur de
l'ump et je participerai au débat dans
l'ensemble de l'opposition parce que
pour moi
et j'allais dire les limites partisane
ne sont pas une frontière et si jean
françois copé était élu président du
parti pensez vous que certains ump
serait alors une sorte de tentation sans
génie de jeu dans la bouche ou sur le la
plume de maurice leroy que ce parait-il
le cas je n'en sais rien je souhaite en
tous les côtés sandrine score quel que
soit le choix reste à l'intérieur de
l'ump car ils sont une des richesses de
l'ump tout comme les radicaux comme les
gaullistes comme les libéraux on va
passer au jeudi
l'actualité est bien elle est marquée
par l'annoncé des suppressions d'emplois
dans l'entreprise automobile peugeot
citroën un choc pour la france voilà
comment le premier ministre a réagi aux
8000 suppressions de postes chez psa
d'ici 2014 la principale usine touchée
est celle d'aulnay sous bois en seine
saint denis allard au delà des
suppressions de postes et du désarroi
des salariés
et bien c'est tout un département qui
est touché par cette annonce comme le
montre ce reportage de paul bouffard le
coup de massue dépasse largement les
grilles de l'usiné
kader travail pour emma france un sous
traitant du site d'aulnay avec ses
collègues ils sont les premiers
fournisseurs de peugeot citroën
ils fabriquent les ossatures en tôle des
voitures
aujourd'hui l'inquiétude est générale
ils ont une famille ils ont des crédits
ils ont acheté des maisons ils ont les
habitent dans le secteur dont il y en a
qui se sont engagés pour acheter des
appartements donc s'ils sont vraiment
pris à la gorge
si on n'a pas de garantie on
on a des doutes et la crainte des
salariés c'est que si demain fr nous si
on peut fermer
longue de choc frappe toute la région
3000 salariés sont licenciés des clients
qui ne viendront plus chez jean louis
bouchet depuis 46 ans la fermeture va
fragiliser l'économie locale sa forme
est plus commerce le cacher la sortie de
la gare ça fait quand même beaucoup de
personnes qui ont un emploi alors café
le matin vous avez un massage d'autobus
fini service il travaillera plus 400
familles de la commune sont concernés
par l'annoncé du groupe
selon le maire ici les services sociaux
sont déjà saturées et psa sur le départ
c'est aussi un manque à gagner important
pour les finances de la ville
le départ de psa pour rooney c'est 4
millions d'euros en moins au budget
annuellement 4 millions d'euros c'est
deux crèches en investissement et c'est
le fonctionnement pour un an de très
gros services comme le service de
l'éducation et le cerveau de la
prévention sécurité devant l'usiné
beaucoup de questions restent pour
l'instant sans réponse combien de
salariés seront reclassés combien
devront finalement quitté la région jean
relation va parler dans quelques
secondes de ce plan social des raisons
de la compétitivité
mais d'abord on l'a bien vu dans ce
reportage l'impact que cela peut avoir
et bien au-delà de la simple cuisine
mais sur le département sur la ville
pour l'avoir vécu comme et du travail
c'est un choc
d'abord pour les salariés et leurs
familles h pour les salariés les sous
traitants et les entreprises sous
traitantes parce que derrière 8000
emplois il y en a bien d'autres en
chaîne enlevés et emerson
vous allez avoir une entreprise
sous-traitante et on l'entendait et qui
vont bien au delà seine-saint-denis et
et vous l'avez tout simplement dans la
vie locale
parce que vous avez là l'un des supports
de la vie locale qui est l'activité
économique
et ce moment de choc je me souviens mois
ces grands moments dans les ardennes
quand j'étais ministre est toujours un
moment humain particulièrement
douloureux et qui doit nous amener
d'ailleurs à ne pas avoir des mots
définitifs ou à utiliser cette douleur
à des fins qui seraient détournés
attention aux mots qui blessent au faux
espoirs il faut construire un avenir
pour ces salariés et il faut construire
un avenir pour l'industrie
c'est ça l'enjeu quand nous vivons un
tel drame parce que c'est un drap but et
je pense que le président de la
république quand il a exprimé sa très
vive préoccupation
il est tout simplement dans la diversité
politique de ce que nous sommes à un
homme qui aujourd'hui exerce comme
président la responsabilité et qui voit
des milliers et des milliers de nos
concitoyens touchés de plein fouet et
nous savons bien que ce sujet il est
posée d'autant plus que c'est une
entreprise peugeot qui avait fait choir
rester en france par rapport à une autre
entreprise automobile
rip 45% de la production de peugeot
ce prêt est encore dans l'hexagone c'est
moins le cas de renault d'accord on est
toujours au coeur du problème
ils n'ont pas choisi le low cost et donc
nous devons envisager mais pour une
entreprise de ces nourritures la
compétitivité est ce que la
compétitivité
ça s'appelle la délocalisation moi je ne
me résous pas je pense que la
compétitivité c'est le grand sujet
raison des choix et que je vous l'avais
dit pas choisi le look aussi sont restés
en france
al'inverse d'une autre entreprise
française rappelle renault mais simplon
achaâcha moi je suis dans un département
où il y à flins où je vois la
décélération et où il ya poissy où je
vois le maintien voire le développement
de mon apparence mais pour la france et
pour la balance des paiements française
je rappelle qu' il y a dix ans
l'industrie automobile participer
positivement à notre balance du commerce
extérieur
aujourd'hui c'est négatif nous ré
importons des véhicules de l'extérieur
le vrai sujet aujourd'hui
c est ce que le site france et
compétitive pour une industrie
automobile le sujet sur déposée en
allemagne
j'étais ministre monsieur ars et l drh
de volkswagen la grande crise à l'aise
en 2004 savez c'était très douloureux -
10 % d'emplois mais un débat qui est la
naissance des plans que nous appelons
chez-nous compétitivité rond et à la
portière arrière une réponse
parce que l'allemagne a pratiqué il faut
le dire un plan social est passé de 28
heures 80 28,8 pardonnez-moi les
fractions à 35 heures sans augmentation
salariale compétitivité absolument
drastique avec des accompagnements de
formation professionnelle et avec des
garanties sur l'emploi
ça ça a été le plus allemand eh ben
c'est à mon avis pour reprendre une
formule du président de la république
peut-être ce niveau de dialogue social
cours doit atteindre dans ce pays
naturellement je comprends les exigences
des salariés et de leurs représentants
mais en même temps vous êtes dans une
entreprise privée cette entreprise
privée est ce qu'elle peut continuer à
perdre 200 millions d'euros chaque mois
il faut la mettre en situation de
compétitivité faut par contre est
totalement exigeants sur les mesures de
reclassement d'accompagnement d'ailleurs
les salariés bénéficieront de mesures
que nous avions proposé jean louis
borloo et moi même dans le cadre des
plans de sauvegarde de l'emploi sous
l'autorité de jacques chirac de jean
pierre raffarin puis de dominique de
villepin
philippe varin le patron de psa dit il
faut baisser le coût du travail
il implore parce que l'état de baisser
le coût du travail qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire aujourd'hui peau est-ce qu'il faut
lui répondre oui ou non il faut lui
répondre que le coût du travail naturel
monte est un des facteurs de la
compétitivité n'est pas le seul
recherche développement la formation des
hommes
les modes de financement tout ceci met
naturellement la question de la
compétitivité
quand vous voyez qu'un véhicule à
produire chez nous avec un produit avec
un pays à plus bas coût ces 700 euros de
différence pour un petit véhicule vous
voyez bien que nous avons un défi de
compétitivité qui doit pas être
uniquement l'objet d'affrontements
politiques mais c'est ça la clé demain
de l'emploi
l'accueil d'envoi c'est la compétitivité
de la maison france dans le domaine
industriel et la compétitivité ça passe
aussi par une maîtrise du coût du
travail
aller en ce week-end de 14 juillet on va
terminer avec un rapport du sénat sur
l'état de l'armée française rapport
rendu cette semaine et qui fait le point
sur la réforme engagée en 2000
la conclusion du rapport une impression
de désorganisation généralisée fabrice
qu'une et il a fallu près de trois ans
gouvernement fillon pour mettre en place
son vaste plan de modernisation de la
défense janvier 2011 les trois corps
d'armée mutualisent leurs moyens de
soutien dans 60 base à la clé une
économie estimée aujourd'hui à 6
milliards d'euros
la suppression de dix mille postes et la
satisfaction du ministre de la défense
de l'époque
quelques mois plus tard j'ai effectué
une réforme du ministère qui est une des
réformes les plus accomplis et les plus
achevés qui soit la réalité du terrain
serait bien différente dans les villes
d'abord qui ont vu partir le régiment le
traumatisme est toujours présent les
compensations promises
toujours attendu à l'exemple de metz à
exemple sur les 1500 emplois
administratifs de compensation il y en a
qu il y en a moins de 200 qui ont été
réellement créé donc c'est dramatique
grogne aussi et surtout chez les
militaires qui dénonce de graves
dysfonctionnements
ce double constat est partagé par les
sénateurs de la commission de la défense
dans un rapport rendu public aujourd'hui
il ya un certain nombre de choses qui
doivent être améliorés comme je voulais
10 mai les bases de défense ne souffre
véritablement en ce moment que d'une
chose c'est les crédits qui leur manque
dans ces conditions ce n'est pas la
réforme qui serait à revoir mais les
moyens de sa bonne application et les
sénateurs lance un avertissement au
gouvernement ne faut plus touchés sous
peine de le détruire à l'outil de
défense
donc pour moi c'est une priorité et je
crois que le budget de la défense ne
peut en aucun cas servir de variable
d'ajustement de droite comme de gauche
ces sénateurs demandent au moins un
statu quo budgétaire et que les
engagements pris soient tenus
rien que pour 2012 il manquerait déjà
130 millions d'euros dans les caisses
alors que cette même semaine yeux un
rapport de la cour des comptes incluent
aussi a dressé un bilan négatif de
l'état de l'armée mais là on souligne en
plus l'importance des coûts salariaux
alors que les effectifs sont en baisse
finalement se retrouve dans une analyse
un peu non pas contradictoire mais où on
a à la fois l'armée qui manque
cruellement d'argent mais aussi qui dans
certains domaines dépense trop est-ce
que
est ce que tout ça est mal organisée
encore que les cas l'armée par deux des
mois en cette période de fêtes
nationales puisque nous vivons tout un
week-end de fête nationale
d'abord elle est engagée elle est
engagée et effectué au nom de la france
j'allais dire un engagement courageux
pensons à nous hommes et aux femmes en
afghanistan
pensons à ceux qui ont permis en côte
d'ivoire de retrouver une situation
équilibrée
le problème est de savoir est ce que
nous avons les moyens et la capacité
d'avoir une armée au service de la
politique étrangère de l'animal
organiser la transformation
jamais un corps social ne se transformer
aussi vite et aussi fortement que les
militaires
quand on est passé de la de la
conscription la professionnalisation
aujourd'hui organisation des bases de
défense
nous savons à la fois dans le rapport
parce qu'il faut aller un peu plus loin
et regarder le rapport positif les bases
de défense simplement des problèmes
d'ajustement de taille de base de
défense
on sait qu'une bonne base de défense
c'est 5000 hommes en même temps il ya
des questions d'aménagement du
territoire
on l'a vu dans les propos quarter final
nos colères et donc les ajustements ce
que nous partageons j'allais dire sur
tous les bancs de la commission parce
que j'appartiens à cette commission
c'est une volonté à ce que les crédits
de la défense ne servent pas d'arv
variable d'ajustement au budget après je
pars nation ce que dit le président
carrère nous préparons et ils vont
bientôt et publié d'autres rapports
notamment sur la question de la
dissuasion nucléaire ou la mauvaiseté à
l'unanimité maintient la dissuasion
nucléaire
à l'exception d'une abstention et nous
partageons aussi le rôle stratégique
d'un certain nombre d'industries de
défense qui bénéficient d'ailleurs tout
simplement l'industrie industrie
aéronautique industrie électronique et
cette réalité là quand on parle de
réindustrialisation du pays
attention l'industrie de défense je lire
malheureusement moins qu'aux états unis
est un outil d'industrialisation et en
même temps c'est d'abord un outil au
service d'une politique
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup de m'avoir
invité
donc nous nous retrouvons nous la
semaine prochaine même lieu même heure
pour une nouvelle émission au revoir au
revoir michael au revoir